so I grew up in a little town called
ujjain which is in the central part of
India and I was into studying a lot more
than Sports and and those other things
the desire to study hard came from just
the background of where my parents had
come from my dad's side of family was
full of Engineers all his brothers were
engineers my dad was in Indian railways
he was a mechanical engineer so I was
very obviously fascinated by oh how do
trains run and how do engines work I am
Priyanka Vergara and this is my journey
to becoming a Google developer advocate
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
into ninth grade it was very clear that
I wanted to be an engineer I decided to
come to the US to do my masters and I
wanted to change the focus a little bit
from Electronics to computer science
because that's kind of where I was
seeing most of the job opportunities we
had to take out a significant amount of
student loans so for me it was like a
huge responsibility in terms of risk
like after doing your Master's six
months after you have to start paying
that loan so you have have to make sure
you get the job
[Music]
18 months
they basically put everything on the
line like all the savings that they had
that just kept kept me motivated and
pushing through as much as anything else
as soon as I graduated I really wanted
to see my parents because I didn't see
them for two years when I was studying
so I paid for their ticket to get here
and they spent the graduation with me
which was
a really proud moment because I
they had never stepped away from the
country ever and this was the first time
they were sitting in an international
flight coming to see me and I was very
proud to be able to give them that
experience
they did say that we don't have to do
this because it was still a hard time
because we had to still pay the loans
and everything I was very determined I
was like I'm not walking
the graduation without you and I wanted
to do that
for me selfishly because I would not
want to walk without anybody in the
stands looking at me graduations
[Music]
foreign
from there I tried being a sales
engineer and that's kind of how I
explored this whole different area of
working in the technology and software
industry but working closer to the
problem statement working closer to the
customer that interest Grew From just
helping One customer to another to
another into creating videos and helping
a broader set of developers and
customers at the same time than I was
like this is great I want to do more of
this and that's kind of how I
transitioned into being a developer
Advocate and I enjoy being closer to
like what developers are feeling what
problems are they facing how do we help
solve them I remember what is
the advice I would give to a 16 year old
girl in India is to just follow your
passion and follow your dream it might
look like it's far-fetched but don't let
it don't let it stop you coming to the
US studying
um with a huge amount of loan at the
back of my mind was hard but if I didn't
take that step
I don't think I would be here if you can
dream it you can do it so dream it
[Music]